madam president mr
president ladies and gentlemen
european parliamentarians
first of all i would like to thank you for
this invitation which has been
given to us to give the debriefing both of the
visit to turkey but also of
the european council and you know that i  I have
always had and I have at heart
this strengthening of the links between the
various institutions the
European Council and the European Parliament at
work through the debris of the
concert hostages who are regularly
addressed
I will first talk about Turkey and
our visit  joint meeting in Ankara
before tackling the other points on the
agenda of the European Council in March
with regard to relations with
Turkey
they have been, as you know, difficult
for many years we have
discussed Turkey during the
European concerts eleven times since I
took office as President of
the European Council,
that shows the serious and
delicate nature of this  your relationship in March
we adopted a clear,
solid statement expressing a possible
positive agenda but which would be progressive,
proportionate and reversible with an
appointment clause for the
European meeting in June
and this statement paved the way  to
this visit to ankara with regard to
this protocol incident
i have on several occasions expressed my
regret publicly for the situation
which has been created
regret vis-à-vis name of the
commission the vis-à-vis the whole
of those who felt offended
the concrete facts are known the
protocol team of the council did not have access
to the meeting room before the start of
the meeting and the committee did not
send its protocol team in
advance  teams therefore did not have access to the
seating arrangement before the start of
the meeting
we are committed our souls a van der
leyen and myself to ensure that
this situation cannot happen
again  ire in the future have given you
instructions to this effect to our
protocol and diplomatic teams
I know that these circumstances brought you to
several of you considered
that at the time
I should have acted differently it is a
criticism that I naturally hear
but at that moment and without their cult
we all have today I
decided not to react further so as not
to create a political incident that I
thought was even more serious which would have taken
the risk  to ruin months of
political and diplomatic preparation
of efforts by all the teams on
the European level
I naturally measure that the images
may have given many women the feeling
of being offended and I would like to
reaffirm my total complete
absolute absolute commitment  to support women to support
gender equality this is an issue
that I have been able to address regularly in
the case of my political career
during our discussions with the
president outside the two areas  de diane
the president ursula van halen and
myself have had the opportunity to
forcefully and firmly express our positions regarding
the withdrawal of turkey from the
istanbul convention in
recent days several of you
no you are writing on behalf contacted for me
propose to use this incident to
defend even more strongly the role
of women's rights and I wish to
seize this outstretched hand I wish to
take advantage of this dynamic to try
to move forward in a constructive way, for
example to be concrete you can
count on my commitment
and  if we make the best efforts to
try to mobilize the member states and
to try to unblock this proposal
for a directive relating to a better
balance between men and women
among the non-executive directors
of companies listed on the stock exchange,
I am also ready of course to m  engage
on priorities with you other than,
for example, the crucial issue
of equal pay
the pay gap  n between men
and women in the european union
and more than 14%
it has changed very little over the
last decades
and this situation is simply not
acceptable, even so i am prepared to
examine the proposal for  a possible
formation of the council on
gender equality but did gentlemen allow
me now to address the substance of
the meeting in ankara
the objective of the meeting was to
try to bring the culture to a more
constructive way or in all  less
negative case with the european union attempted
to defuse tensions and to
clearly emphasize the rule of law
on democratic values ​​and on
human rights the presidency of alain
and myself have the opportunity  to say
struggling in r2 yan you we are ready to
put on the table a positive
but conditional agenda proportional is
reversible this requires progress in
several areas including of course
human rights but also the  es
relations with Greece or the
Cyprus issue,
we have expressed our deep
concerns regarding the rule of
law, fundamental rights, the withdrawal
of the Istanbul Convention,
but also freedom of expression
and the targeting of political parties
and  media
extensive cooperation with turkey
is difficult to envisage if negative measures
were to continue in
these areas
exploratory talks between
greece and turkey have started
talks on the settlement of the
Cyprus issue are also due to start
this week under the auspices of the
united nations and we reminded
turkey to engage
constructively we also underlined
the importance of the role of the union as
an active observer in the calm of this
hall process within the united nations
we also identified the
possible pillar for this age end to
economic cooperation the possible
modernization of the study of  a of
the customs union
secondly the question of migration
the need to be committed in good faith
on this subject but also the question
of interpersonal contacts and
mobility
the question of the regional role of turkey
was of course addressed the questions
of  foreign affairs
the geopolitical question, for example the
situation in libya in syria or even in
nagorno karabakh,
we were able to raise this question of the
memorandum of understanding signed between
turkey and libya on
maritime delimitation and recalled the clear position
of the european council on  On this subject, I
would like to point out that before this mission
to Turkey, I had had the opportunity to
go to Libya and Tunisia the two
previous days. It has been decided at
the European Council that in June the
heads of government will once
again consider  on this relationship between the
european union and turkey in order
to consider that it follows on the basis of the
hope of the progress which can be
recorded  s will give to this
relationship between the european union and
turkey
10:01 am national parliaments remains that as
soon as possible nineteen treaty discussion yes
just needs a darling sow in this post
getting art citizens registered shareholders
is this possible some countries of skulls
and vaccine distribution 1,  10 m bales m6
between them will find in principle on the 26th
to our population bezis a decree confesses
serious in itself from cyrine boat world series
by leader yes you have two koreas pair
trade show in spirit solidarity and was
found from wick has besides that  'such an
operation either in the finger
frustration is interrupted eberle
digital city fix you will be discussing
6:07 p.m. effective asked oxford and
soon as possible
in fact said international machines
countries where he already puts himself exhibited with sims
will have two groups
sentheim we decided  to be continued to
strength in response to pandemic under
vaccine sherin mechanism in addition to
prove axis during a meeting where he is
warm  hot information pointing black
dog to huy for title my visit to
georgia moldova something drags on we found
in principle is an excerpt paintsil
meeting yes da little troll concludes we
are bleeding gypsies kate
and industrial policy and i economy in
digital since end  November solution is
twice less to come here said nasri said
it again to be found in and out in your
arms and work we say international we
fire it will diploma baccalaureate at one for men right
at this internship and genomics b
without more with a  pop and economy
finally we welcome headline in dubai john
drydock at the stars of facetime and
novelties there was only one false is
difficult nineteen el wakt clause
the study aids vaccine and supply chain
online america's sweetheart s entry
i speak that  le challenge stradale
we want to build and friendship une
forge un new deal atlantique mindset
foundation for news corporation is you
know to get high speed bike and run
relays ni brief un you will meet i  n
mitchum des mambas served in parliament
eileen besides barefoot he follows me
the ice of official endorsement but she ain't
you physics-chemistry especially we say
international sin where there are notes and
sweatshirts and jews inc we wipe our  looks
is at an influence of the world the tool
is georgian ukraine au afrique a look
at you in flames at destination to be my
[ __ ] is all clad china brasil india
indian united states at breakneck speed
barefoot in this album go in sibiu in the
running  before promised to as forlan
nutritive be anti fifty internal to
carbon pricing and usual beasts or
albi hopkins and union this burgundy this
look is how f7 global standard
djezzy exito worse to isner jojoy stand-up
privacy says yeah 6 following for
example  a story says work and
digital text and the last week two
faces in the world proposes ding ding
legislation artificial intelligence
yes on lé dinh bà example says luis
sitting in the drive in the drive-in
site freenews multilateralism a f  ois
pessimiste autonomy strategy
and we can do so much more like you
president of the mullahs then the
president is founded the rule to what
charles michel
members and to be here comes the
expected to be treated with it in touch
with the goal like crazy dance  battle
note notification include because i'm
not have you done
by nico  you need is now
at 9:15 a.m. to September 19
in fine it takes major representatives
for ford legislation to prevent
they fight offline and online
but manninger aride project lincoln and
martin is democratizing thrown case nor
down this year permanent site
once we are we  would have said rick steiner
go very fine noises to the channel life
to maxim at the same time thanks to a prize
each inhabitant of great
genius medicine bayonne text detroit sesame
and faïza a syndrome in the imf
campaign in europe in the tac au tac campaign in
tempo district of andar opinionway
millionen mymensingh a health section
with his friend they say they have come rhône
trail 6 million will only be 12 until
the photos of the  ballet number to hognoul to
other lady 15th tchi ​​tchi ​​kong released
respective chances hot and chips
african armies were gucci exhibition
we must bring back from the commission is
put to the award-winning films glue and
guillaume des european commission and
catherine rich 7 p.m. match management
imd commission and  in north in finistère
imagine trams formed with different
hypotheses reference positions and the
commission m i invite the other
institutions of the european union to
follow our example the commission
certainly but also the board
of directors of the european parliament
the other bodies of the  union still have a
lot of work to do,
the commission will therefore soon organize
a meeting with the other institutions
to discuss how we can all
do
better women represent half of the
european population and this must be
reflected in the institutions at the heart
of europe ladies and gentlemen
members of parliament have march european council
heads of state or government have  been
very clear respect for
women's rights and raad an important prerequisite for
a resumption of dialogue with turkey
and the expansion of our
common program but it is far from being the only
prerequisite in ankara i
again  carry the message that turkey
should continue the escalation
we deserve eastern mediterranean it
must accept the judgments of the
european court of human rights these are
our conditions for strengthening our
economic cooperation with turkey
and for engaging in high-
level dialogues  on topics such as
climate change public health
and regional issues
under these conditions it would also be
much p  more easy deliberate new
money to help turkey
take care of more than four
million syrian refugees
we also salute the efforts
that turkey is making in this respect ladies and
gentlemen northern deputies when we
talk about respect and  dignity
we must not limit ourselves
to equality between men and women the issue
is no longer broad
we cannot tolerate that
lgbt areas are multiplying in our member states
we cannot tolerate that the roma
are discriminated against in europe and we cannot
absolutely cannot tolerate the
ugly face of anti-Semitism and racism
that it displays including the smallest corner of
our union europe you so much
better than that
a sum times time mr
hyde opportunities willard the crowd of love
with you cam  from rygaard the only one
besides facetime the causes of the
crises of hyundai believin and unit
schulze up to 10 motorcycles united in
diversity family of the screens of the man
the old groupies p  olitici president
and webber the floor at the commune cannot
deliberate colleagues our colleagues sad
european chirac what was followed four
things in december